[Music]
foreign
[Music]
techniques in getting the film look in
Capture One
capture one is an amazing editing
software and if you are to ask me it's a
better alternative to Lightroom
I just love capture one and after I
tried it a couple years ago I left live
stream completely and I did look back
for a second the interface is much
easier to understand in my opinion and
it offers more complex tools that you
would generally find in video editing
software
I'll be showcasing some of these tools
throughout the video so watch till the
end and remember I put chapters in the
playback timeline so you can find
exactly what you need faster
this will only be a quick introduction
to capture launch and a short take on
how I added my shots step by step so if
you find this video helpful let me know
in the comments and I'll make a longer
video where I added more of these shots
these images were taken on my trip to
Bucharest where I did a little street
photography video presenting the Sony
field simulation picture profiles which
will get you better color straight out
of camera so if you're interested in
Sony film simulations you can find the
settings on my website link description
down below
it was a basic rule my main editing
steps are contrast color correction
color grade and lastly red isolation
effects
let's start from scratch select an image
and press F7 for new variant
what I think is most important when
starting is bring the contrast to your
design liking so tone is the first thing
that you need to decide on before diving
into color because you can have great
colors but if your overall tone is off
then it's all junk in my opinion
I like to start by lifting the
brightness and bring down the exposure
to give myself a flatter image doing so
will bring up more details in the
shadows and reduce the highlights giving
the image an overall softer tone
and that is because the brightness will
control more of the darker mid-tone
areas while exposure controls more of
the higher end of the image meaning the
mid-tones and the highlights
next to make this easier and focus only
on contrast let's reduce the saturation
of the image completely
when working with contrast I have a very
simple and basic rule which is what you
want to show and what you want to hide
so by using the curves tool you brighten
up the parts of the image that you want
to show and darken the bars that you
want to hide
but how do you know which part of the
image corresponds to which part of the
curve by hovering over the image in the
curves panel you will see an orange line
will appear showing us exactly where
that area is falling in the Curve
so to start off let's start two points
and areas where we want modifications
and make an s-curve remember what I said
hi stuff in the shadows and lift the
brightness in areas of Interest I keep
on shifting until you're satisfied with
the end result
this will take a little bit of
experience so don't worry if you don't
get it the first time
I just like to bring up the mid tones
and the highlights and cross the Shadows
just a little bit to guide the eyes
where they should look at
eyes in general are most attracted to
areas with most brightness contrast and
saturation so use that information next
time to help the eyes find their way to
the subject
[Music]
there's so many videos out there telling
you that for a good image to happen you
need to make an s-curve in every window
you can find and that is so not true in
fact you can make a single point in the
mid-tone area and drag it all the way to
the top
I'll give you a soft faded look to your
images which is more dreamy you can
further refine it to your own liking so
feel like what matters the most in the
end is the mood of the image what do you
want to express or how do you want
people to feel like when they look at
your image
so next question would be RGB or Luma
because you might have noticed we have
so many panels here in capture one and
that's exactly what I'm talking about
compared to Lightroom Capture One offers
you greater control so you can finally
adjust each part of the image for better
results
Lightroom doesn't even have an option to
separate RGB from the Luma curves and
that is important because by working
only with Luma you can adjust the
overall contrast of the image without
affecting the saturation of it
you can work in both RGB or Luma at the
same time and it's nothing wrong with
that you just need to know when and how
you want to use it and capture one will
give you more options and control in
that matter
so now that we have brought the tonality
of the image to a point where the
subject is put in Focus let's compress
the image just a bit
as you like to work with levels very
much because it helps me compress image
or manipulate image data in different
points more easily explained lets you
play around with brightness and contrast
by moving different image data like
black and white point and also midtowns
the film shots are like to compress the
highlights by quite a bit and maybe
bring up the Black Point by about let's
say seven and you can also adjust the
mid tones if needed
usually after all this I go back into
the curves tab to adjust the contrast if
I feel it's too flat
as you can see it's a back and forth
kind of a job when it comes to contrast
where you need to go back and further
refine until you're satisfied with the
look of the image
so for me personally this was it for the
contrast part maybe we'll come back
later after the color grading to adjust
it even more now for the color part
let's go into the color menu found and
above tabs
basically it's pretty simple and I have
a rule which is very helpful what color
do I like and which one I want shifted
analyze the whole image look what colors
are present in the image and then ask
yourself which ones I like and which
ones I want shifted
remember what I said when talking about
contrast
it all depends on the mood of the photo
and how you want the people to feel like
when they look at your image keep that
in mind because we'll use it throughout
color as well so for me this image is
pretty magenta and the colors are pretty
boring
like my images a bit cyan so I'll just
bring down the temperature and the tint
more towards green
[Music]
it's already looking better you can see
how just by Shifting the temperature and
the tint we can make huge improvements
in color and this might seem very simple
and basic but I cannot stress enough
about it in my course over the internet
I keep seeing so many tutorials doing so
much intense image processing using the
qualifier brushes and all kind of stuff
but if we understand the basics we don't
need to complicate ourselves with
impractical techniques
that's why I think the simpler the great
the better and by easing our workflow
the more enjoyable it gets and this type
of workflow will offer you fluidity and
will ease your editing process next
let's realize the colors for a second
here is another really cool Capture One
tool called the color ranges which can
access by pressing on these three dots
you can adjust the areas of influence
for each color range but you can also
see exactly what colors are present in
the scene and how much each channel is
affecting on their own
okay I get that but why is this
important for us it's important because
we know exactly which colors are
problematic and which part of the image
should be further adjusted as you can
see there are some Reds but not much
there's more color in the orange and
yellow ranges also in the green and blue
tonalities
also there are no pings or magentas and
they're very little Reds so mostly we'll
be working with green blue and oranges
okay good so what I'll do is even the
color channels trying to balance all the
colors and focus them on only two
complementary ones which will be blue
and orange maybe sounds complicated so
I'll just go ahead and show exactly what
I'm talking about you can also bring up
the saturation to see if there are any
mistakes or any color separation
happening over the image
bring up the saturation also helps me
decide which colors I want to saturated
to make them less dominant and help
balance out colors
I'll just saturate the greens pretty
heavily the saturate just a bit the
yellows and saturated Blues oranges and
reds
just by balancing out colors in this way
we can achieve a natural complementary
color palette and organic color
transition making it look more like film
[Music]
this was the color correction and color
grading step which are the more
complicated steps so stay with me
because we're almost done finally we
have artistic color grade and retilation
effects
I like a little bit of green in my shot
so in the color balance Wheels I'll add
some green yellow in the highlights and
some blue in the shadows just like so
it's looking great as it is so no
further complications for this one but
there's one thing I want to show you is
how you can create this effect
differently if you want more control
over how much the image is being
affected and I'll show you exactly how
to do that
in the layers channel right click on the
plus icon and select the new filled
adjustment layer now adjust the Luma
range for the desired area I'll go for
the highlight
once something soft and subtle to
prevent color separation which can
happen even on 14-bit raw files if
you're not paying attention
hit OK and then in the color balance
Wheels add your desired color this way
you can Define exactly the area which
should be affected by the color wheels
and how much and that's pretty cool
right last step is halation I made a
couple lation brushes which you can find
on my website together with other film
products so basically after you install
the brushes in capture one source file
which I can show you exactly in the next
tutorial go to exposure tab open the
style brushes and you will see multiple
options including light leaks effects
blood testing each until you decide
which one best fits your image now
delete all the layers and I personally
will use the Revelation 2 and 3.
together with the Revelation light leak
some of them will be strong by default
so bring down the opacity for more
subtle effects
right click for the brush menu where you
can adjust size flow and opacity I
usually go for something soft and just
start painting over areas of high
contrast for the relation to show up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's put some light leaks in the corner
for more interesting natural analog
effect
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you can check and compare the before and
after and this is looking great huge
differences from start to finish just by
doing some simple adjustments
if you like these brushes you can find
them on my website link description down
below and if you want a more in-depth
tutorial let me know in the comments
section and I'll create a longer video
showing exactly how I edit multiple
shots for my trip to Bucharest also
subscribe and ring the notification Bell
to be notified of that video coming out
till next time take care and remember
have fun
[Music]